i want to address the fact that sona
can't be here today because
uh and she's such a regular part of the
podcast and this i find absurd
she's on a book tour wow she wrote a
book
about her misadventures and she's on a
book tour and if you had told me
when i met sona all those years ago and
she became my kooky assistant
that i would lose her for for a period
of time because she's out promoting the
book she wrote
i'd have laughed you off the face of the
earth god bless her god bless her she is
i mean this is proof
as the great don king would say
only in america
only in america
incredible should we address the david
in the room well that's what i'm getting
to because
sona's so busy now with she has these
twins mikey and charlie
uh i prefer mikey
i have beef i have major beef with
charlie but because uh and she now she
has a book
and i think she's starting a chain of
restaurants
stop no stop off at goofballs
um order your food and watch it not show
up oh
i'm sorry
but um because uh she can't be here and
she's so busy i have an assistant uh who
took over for sona
you know it's i'm hoping a temporary
arrangement no
sorry but we love him well we'll get to
that david i'm not firing you here i'm
just letting you know that it's
imperative so many times i know that
so david hopping took over david hopping
was sona's assistant
because she didn't want to do anything
and um
and now
david's pretty much my full-time
assistant until sona's done promoting
her other schemes
so isn't it crazy sona has a book
yeah it's really good it is very i've
read it it's basically a how-to for me
taking over
did you ever think and ultimately the
way this should end is you write a book
and go on a tour do i get my own
assistant yes yes yes this is what i'm
trying to tell you is this is those
russian dolls a doll within a doll
within a doll within a doll you now
read sona's book okay learn how to
totally screw me over and not do your
job then you write a book about that and
then you take off then we hire someone
who will fill in for you should we have
maddie do it daddy ogden oh okay
very she's a very fashionable young
fashionable she's always wearing
different cool outfits
and uh she's crucial to the running of
the podcast yes yeah so okay she'll take
over then wow you've got this all worked
out yeah it's a big plan i've had for a
while
i would like to point out quickly that
uh you have your own podcast i do and
what's it called again uh it's called
back to the best okay back to the best
and it's about it's about like 90s early
2000s nostalgia okay um our instagram is
at bttp podcast if you want to follow us
knock it off you asked this is the one
you know i didn't ask him i didn't ask
him for our website is
um ttpodcast.com nice oh my god okay uh
everyone's got their own scheme yeah
also he sells watches out of the trunk
of his car yeah
i'll tell you something i'll give you a
discount yeah okay they're all really
good high quality digital watches from
the late 80s yeah wow yeah yeah i just
like to plug my tupperware business i
did a couple of parties
okay
i would like to plug something i'm doing
at some point oh wait i'm not doing
anything about this just remember
i'm happy for sona yeah that she's hit
the big time
and
she had an event
last night i think in seattle at a
bookstore and apparently tons of people
showed up alex was so full yeah so great
that was packed yeah there's i was
probably always the hope maybe conan
will be there people show up i don't
know um and i think that's you know
probably a lot of the appeal of the book
who can say uh i'm excited for it i
really seen the print copy because your
name is just redacted
the entire book
what i love about her book is that
there's so much about it that's real
it's it is real
she's telling real stories they're all
honest to god true and um wow what an
unprofessional relationship we've had
for years i know the dynamic between you
when i was reading this book sometimes
my my jaw was dropping yeah yeah what
who's more wrong here
these are two idiots two idiots two
idiots who've been it is proof there is
a god yeah because whoever put us
together has a sense of humor
it is i love lucy yeah but ricky and
lucy are both insane
uh so yeah anyway i'm very happy for her
and david if this means you're here
then it must be a good
sign that all's going our way because
you're a lovely fellow oh thank you
and i know that you enjoy working with
me i do you don't have to say that
you're not you're not
interesting i share you with our
producer long time producer now of
almost 30 years jeff ross yes so you're
technically jeff's assistant and my
assistant
but i get the feeling
that
if push came to shove you'd be more
loyal to me oh i don't know if i feel
comfortable answering that you don't
have to because you shouldn't just right
out there watching no jeff is out there
watching this but as your legal counsel
i advise you not to answer thank you
thank you i silence i want to do one of
those things where i like put my hand
over the mic and push the mic away
no jeff's car needs to go into the shop
and you tell me i ask you to take my car
into the shop and you say well no i have
to take jeff's car into the shop and i
tell you
no cancel that take mine
what do you do
i
i feel like jeff would probably just
tell me to take yours but also jeff
trusts me more with his car than you do
well first of all
i drive a rolls-royce okay made of
marzipan
yep i'm a very
i wanted to i wanted to i wanted to show
people my status and i thought i'll get
a rolls royce
but then i thought no it should be it
should be even more effete than that so
i had it made by a great baker engineer
out of marzipan and i drive it around
and it's got a horn that goes
can you push his mic away yeah yeah
and then there's a car it has a car
alarm that goes i'm
uh yeah
remember when i had you i parked it in
the sun and it started to melt and i had
you move it yeah that was a good time
good improv david i said yeah i remember
that i forgot to say and yeah
yeah yes no no i know yeah and then i
moved it
yeah
and then i moved it
listen i think you're um
i do think you're a terrific person and
i'll say this about david i call him
first ring hopping whenever i call him
on his cell he picks up
usually on the first ring wow
sona
15 rings
goes to someone else's voicemail
then i'd have to like say i mean trying
i would send her telegrams i would drive
to her house
the contrast between
david and sona when i'm trying to
contact them absolutely amazing all
right
i love sona but i would choose you yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i think mikey i think mikey and charlie
would choose you
as the parent right there as the primary
caregiver oh please she's already lost
two of them
although she's only two she loves
both of her kids she lost because she's
on the book tour oh god no she took them
on the book tour she did she didn't she
did i heard them in the background
well i heard you know mikey
oh charlie what's your beef with charlie
charlie didn't laugh when i tried to
entertain them both mikey gave it up
charlie was just sat there and stared at
me and sort of looked like eh i don't
get it i'll come around and i went
through that in the 90s i don't need
that again people's first reaction
i'm sorry i cut you off you were saying
something i don't remember
perfect
well david that is so david hopping